boy is it exciting anytime these two
players meet in round 4 of the 2017 Tata
Steel chess tournament held in Wieck and
Z the first super grandmaster event of
every chef's year Magnus Carlsen played
wayy with the white pieces and this
position occurred on the board what you
may not know is that this is truly the
critical moment of this game it's
surprising because there's still equal
material for everybody it doesn't feel
like either side is about to lose the
thread but there are two potentially
very big weaknesses in this position for
black they are the bishop on g6 and the
pawn on d6 now I've been a little bit
vague by highlighting those weaknesses
but that's because I want to give you a
chance with just that small amount of
information to think and play like
Magnus Carlsen himself so on that note
you have a moment to pause the video and
think how would you try to execute a
plan that maybe takes advantage of the
bishop and the pollen at the same time
okay assuming you pause the video it's
time to continue the move played was the
move evaluated right here in front of
you by stock fish that is Queen to c1
now forget about the computers of
reasons for this move in the evaluation
let's try to learn from this what is it
about this move that is so strong well
as long as this Queen maintains her very
very strong outpost here not only is she
sort of threatening at the dark squares
kind of a bluff but the main thing she's
doing is both preventing this F pawn
from expanding to expose this bishop and
she's also keeping an eye on her own
potential weakness on d6 neither one of
those things is is really an issue as
long as the Queen is on the board
maintaining her control
so Queen to c1 as subtle as it is is
also very very critical for for white to
gain a potential advantage in this
position the Queen's were traded because
the plan I highlighted about this pawn
running wild is exactly why you wouldn't
see certainly a move like Queen e5 now F
4 comes in with tempo and then Bob's
your uncle there on g6 and if you play
Queen f6 really white has no reason but
not to just go full steam ahead anyway
even if I'm not trapping the bishop by
force gaining this kind of space and
launching an attack over here is not
something that the young Chinese wanted
to deal with because of that he took on
c1 and now started to see the bigger
picture in the position and realized
that this d6 pawn is not something he
really wants white to
have time to gang up on this is a very
instructive point for everybody at home
too because you start to realize that
developing plans at a high level is
about bigger picture thinking seeing the
forest through the trees you have to
recognize that if why just given time
here you might see this bishop go to b3
holding d5 you might see magnet start to
prepare a a plan of doubling the rooks
on the D file and if you sort of remove
all the all the smoke of where the
pieces are now and just think about
where do you want your pieces to be you
can see that black might have some
problems here but this d6 mom being a
backward pawn a backward pawn is a pawn
that cannot be defended by pawns must be
defended by pieces and it's a big
weakness here because of that way you
played them of d5 but magnus carlsen was
ready he played 'if i've counteracting
this idea he doesn't want to make a big
trade and simplify and certainly doesn't
want to bring this pony into a square
where he might get active on the dark
squares instead magnus plays a5 and we
suddenly see that white has a huge space
advantage even if I don't get to trap
the bishop if I'm white this pawn
majority is going to lead to good things
only good things after Knight to c5 way
he does establish the pony on on a
better square than it was initially
certainly on d7 but it came with a price
surprisingly the knight on e4 actually
allows white to play an aggressive plan
and and take advantage of this pawns new
duties the new duties are that this pawn
must guard the knight on e4 so first
magnus carlsen
finds a very good move here to take
advantage of this Knight ever ever
getting out of this precarious position
he plays the move b4x clam takes away
the move Knight to c5 guard set square
and now after the move g5 of course a
very good attempt by wayy to try to
undermine the center obviously we can
see here of magnus carlsen captures then
way you would be more than happy with
that but Magnus was just ignoring full
steam ahead again the point is this pawn
is now overworked and overworked piece
has too many responsibilities of course
why would why would want to get the C
file so if any random move is made we'll
see that the capture here is going to
force pawn capture because it rook takes
will win tonight and now the C file
becomes a serious problem so you're
starting to see how all of these bigger
picture plans are coming together for
white now does that mean the way he was
lost you're probably not quite yet in
the game he probably could have taken on
f4 even after C
and then played the move f6 though as
magnus carlsen said himself about this
position in the commentary room at the
Astra Sarah Wan does black really have a
blockade Magnus joke that he doesn't
really believe in blockades even with
this Knight and pawn guarding everything
for the King to enter probably why can
both consider capturing here to try to
get the C file as well as c5 to try to
kick that night white is certainly the
aggressor and it would have been a tough
position for ye to defend but lost it
was not the giant the young Chinese did
not go for that instead he got a little
panicked he played the MU c5 which as
you can start to see from our buddy
stockfish above my head really gives
white some big advantages after Knight
to b5 these pawns are just undermined
they can't move because the knight hangs
but if they just sit we're just going to
start capturing and in fact it was it
was so precarious for black that after
just two more moves way he shocked
everybody including those in the
commentary move by just resigning in
this position he simply threw in the
towel of course the computer evaluation
doesn't disagree that black is losing I
mean white is almost up a full piece a
couple of protected passed pawns moves
like rook takes d5 lose to the move
Knight to c7 which applies a fork of the
Brooks and the knight is still hanging
but maybe maybe way you could have
played Knight to c3 and after captures
captures white needs to find either King
to e4 or work to deed three to guard
this pawn don't just go for a big trade
we're sure magnus carlsen would have
played a move like that and maintained a
very easily winning advantage
nonetheless a little surprising that Wei
Yi resigned so quickly so on that note
we have now shown you the critical
moment of this very exciting game of
course we look forward to many matchups
in the future we always feel like we're
looking into the lens of the future when
Magnus Carlsen and way you play each
other you can get more from this game in
the video library at chess comm and of
course you can follow everything you
need to about the Tata Steel chess
tournament over at chess coms news
division with Peter daughers on site
thanks for watching give us some love
give us a like give us a share and we
will catch you later on chefs calm